now now let's put up where we're
supposed to weigh yeah let's go what are
we supposed to weigh 5'5 is supposed to
be 122 to 150 pounds but men have been
wanting to get laid so much they've been
lying to us about what we're coming to
the ground please
um could you do yeah yeah sorry
we'll go kilograms yeah thank you
there we go so five six five six you're
supposed to be 5 53 to 64 cases
basically what yes yeah yeah yeah you
know five seven
um 55 5 8 57 yeah so we gotta they say
the best the best um they say that the
best uh dating coach for women is a
personal trainer
guys would you say that's true the best
dating coach for women a personal
trainer as it has a lot of benefits yeah
yeah
now now let's go let's go so you know
the average woman a hundred years ago
used to give them seven kids
average woman 100 years ago was like 120
pounds
not 85 percent of women were virgins a
hundred years ago the average bride was
22.
so yeah I would say based on history and
what men have always that's why I said
we'd all be thrown out a hundred years
ago pretty much yep
um so this all of these statistics
from past time to now yep a lot of it is
based on the transformation and
transition of our culture cultural input
and media is I think about six I don't
know how much to say maybe but men's
requirements are still pretty much the
same because biologically we haven't
changed I get what you're saying but
I'll be the same but then as well you
see that you see that the requirements
are still the same their requirements
are the same but are they the same but
for them
providers yeah but it's just that most
women want so much that their money
doesn't provide like my dad for example
is just an average working-class man he
he makes the average salary in the UK
and he's always been able to provide for
me and my mom my mom doesn't work but
that's because my mum doesn't get her
nails done every other week she doesn't
get her hair done everything okay so
it's all about what we're asking
besides
um also historically we said um
I've forgotten about uh but we're
talking about okay and men are men are
no more the same no more the same but
historically most men have not been able
to reproduce historically only 40 of men
have been able to reproduce so the
reality is
men have always never been
in a situation where all men would get a
chance to get a shot at this so when
women try to take things that men and
say oh this and that is actually you
should actually look at yourself and
look at the reason why you as a woman
who historically 80 of women have been
able to reproduce so if now you are not
being you are not able to reproduce as a
woman you should actually be looking at
yourself
the food choices we have now are
completely different which mess up a lot
of things the environment that people's
choices like to eat those things what's
available what's available there's
organic and then there's crap and most
people working class people can afford
the crap which messes up a lot of things
which happen internally that we're not
even knowing you can choose to buy
processed foods you don't have people to
reproduce I'm not talking about
biological I'm talking about most men
historically didn't even make the cut
okay okay so most men wear it rich
enough or maybe they were slaves or
maybe for whatever reason maybe they
couldn't attract a woman I'm not even
talking about what you're talking about
so them saying Oh men don't qualify men
have always never really qualified
but most women have and let's talk about
the culture who's in charge of culture
thank you
the in the the individ who's in charge
of culture is who whichever culture the
person individual is in their culture is
in charge of how they are okay but let's
let's talk about us women right we make
80 of consumer buying decisions cultures
literally designed towards us because we
make up so much of the consumer buying
choice so most of our culture nowadays
we can all agree it's based on money you
know we've all been talking about cost
of living
etc etc everything's based on money if
women are making most of the decisions
for where that money is going all of the
culture around us is going to be
tailored to women
exactly and so it all really starts so
let's let's talk about this
um the women has Christine so finally
pointed out
um we make the consumer buying decisions
so all the companies are marketing
towards women so everything we see on TV
is because women like it the politicians
can't get elected because women you know
it's funny we're so not loyal that we're
not even loyal to political parties so
they'll just give us free stuff and
we'll vote for them
um so yeah women control the politicians
and women control the home because again
you know so many so many moms break up
with the husband and then they're in
control of the next generation of men
and women because they're in control of
the culture of the home or the dads will
be working more and who's in control of
the culture the women so if we're going
to blame the culture let's blame women
so basically but I don't understand the
blame in this well because um my my
thing is that something's always been
like that no it hasn't that's not true
he also just said it does not um what do
you mean settling as in like you said
earlier the men would never the provider
fully but girls were happy to get
married to them but now days okay like
we just know our values like let's talk
about what's up if you know you can have
someone that's way better than but do we
know our value or is our ego just over
inflated because of what we just said I
don't think if everything around us is
tailored towards us right women are
emotional creatures
that we're emotional creatures so if
everything around us is tailored towards
us that means everything around us is
focused on our emotions how to make
women feel better so that's why I
suggest that perhaps it's that women
have an over-inflated ego because I mean
look around look at all this body
positive stuff it's telling women we
have more value than we actually do in
the eyes of men and that's why women are
saying well why am I not getting the man
I want because they're going for men
that they think they deserve because the
culture tells us that we deserve those
men when in reality we might not
let's let's talk about this so I have
let's talk about exchange what is value
all right let's talk about it let's talk
about okay because we always say women
women women are yeah let's we always say
we always say women are settling right
that's always what we say but the
average woman again is 170 pounds right
which is huge um yep fat yep
um 90 have been on birth control yeah um
slept with five to eight men which in
any other time period would be thrown
out disgusting and a hundred years ago
the men would be like that that is the
the town [__] now now the men are like
five that's amazing but it's only
because we're in this time period okay
so so right now we have overweight
[__] yeah that we're we're given to
the men saying
I am the prize
and I can't settle
when really so the real question is
um so okay and they'll say he doesn't
make enough to support oh sorry I think
I'm in the UK so it's 35k here
um but okay so he makes 35k
um
and what else protected he's still
stronger than her so he's still
protecting and
um so you know if a burglar breaks in he
has to die first okay so like right
right you guys all the men know this
right if you if a burglar breaks in if
we're if I live alone and a burglar
comes in suspended yeah exactly so we do
get protection and we do get 35k a month
now remember this is pretty good
considering in all other time periods
you would have been a peasant that's
what we would like to but I don't think
the men nowadays will be that type of
protector and provider anyway
um no money laying in the bed while the
dog gets back they're going to the front
never know what you feel they're gonna
make you push you forward and say go go
that's how I see them in nowadays yeah
well that is that's a better man that's
a holy that's a whole number that's
another debate yeah but if you kind of
man then you should actually be looking
I didn't say that I was going for them